the supreme court just heard oral  argument an incredibly interesting first  amendment case related to students  you might not know this but students do  have first amendment rights  after all public schools are an arm of  the government so if they punish you for  your speech even if you are a minor  student then that might be a violation  of the first amendment and this is an  incredible case where  a student said some curse words on  social media on snapchat  and this was outside of school but  someone brought that  into the school and then the school  punished her for saying these curse  words and so  the question is where does the right of  the students end  can they be punished in school for  something they did outside of school  it's going to be an incredibly  interesting first amendment case and  we'll see where the lines are drawn with  respect to  student rights and so we'll see you in  court